just text your questions and muster
Souter just have been T King Gary
[Music]
good morning everybody it is Monday and
it is tea with Gary Vee
I'm your host gary vay-ner-chuk and I'm
super excited to be here with everybody
trying out a new platform big big shout
out to scream yard we'll see what that's
about and I'm really really darn excited
about this I hope you enjoy today's
episode we got a bunch of great callers
and I'm ready ready go so Dustin you
could throw them up let's go hello good
morning how are you I'm good how are you
I'm super well that's good
first of all thanks for the opportunity
to talk to me about this that's really
cool of course were you from what's your
name my name is Janani I'm from Detroit
it's a real pleasure to me thank you
it's a pleasure as well so my question
is kind of a weird question question
because I'm in a situation that I didn't
so when I initially started doing what i
do i make youtube videos and instagram
videos they're usually comedy related
but because i wanted attention on my
writing okay and people started to like
my acting which is not a bad thing
that's great yeah it takes away from the
opportunity to actually work on my
writing because now people expect videos
like every [ __ ] day and a script
takes work every [ __ ] day so Natalie
so don't make the videos that's that's
where I'm at and I'm like I feel bad cuz
I have people that enjoy my stuff and I
don't want to let them down so now I
feel obligated to make funny but but
you're letting yourself down yeah yeah I
am
listen people were devastated when I
stopped Wine Library TV people said that
I shouldn't make business videos I
shouldn't do that you know you know but
the reality is people were upset when I
stopped so many of my projects
askgaryvee you know dailyvee you know
weekly V which I'm doing but like you
know people will be upset you know how
many people are gonna hit me up once
Coronas over and say why'd you stop
doing tea with Gary D it was the best
thing
did that's all I see on Twitter all day
long best thing I'm doing so the reality
is you know you're trying to give as
much as you can but then the reality is
if you're not in a good place you have
nowhere to give and this is gonna suck
you out if you eventually are doing what
you want to do and who says you can't
come who says you can't right for a good
three weeks and then come hard with a
nice little video and then go back
you're you're being too anal and
structure or like I gotta put one out of
every three days or one day or once a
week you go do what you need to do and
you pop in and make a video when you
want to okay it's really that simple
yeah on your bag and it you get comments
and then you also get caught where the
views aren't as good people get caught
up in the algorithms and the numbers
they're like damn when I was doing you
know you come back three weeks you put
out into the dam why is that 40,000
views instead of 80,000 or 800,000 stead
of 1.3 million whatever your world is so
the reality is is that if you're not
doing you you're not gonna be able to do
for them and so it starts with you the
way to be selfless and give is to
actually be selfish around knowing
yourself that's what you need to do okay
whatever question one other question I
live in Detroit but I want to be a
writer which means I need to be a PA
which means I need to move to Los
Angeles and I have been struggling with
that decision because well it's
expensive as [ __ ] in Los Angeles
but I wanted to know from you if you
were in my position and you were a young
writer you haven't I would I would try
to write one bomb-ass masterpiece on
some old Good Will Hunting [ __ ] and put
it out there and if it doesn't take then
I would go to move to LA and [ __ ]
have a [ __ ] job in the sunshine and
write and [ __ ] chase my dream okay I
can do that got you
thanks ray well you see you got it take
care bee sting
be safe let's keep this going fantasy
football show big ups on Twitter how are
you I am wake what's up on YouTube good
you love the comments coming in yeah
how's it going man it's good bro good
hope you in your family are safe out
there
thank you so so it's a question it's not
really based around myself it's more
based around like messages being sent
out kind of in the media social media
right now it's kind of saying you don't
really need to be productive during this
time you know a lot of people are scared
uncertain that's putting some people
that are getting depressed so do you
feel that's an okay message or how would
you rephrase that message that people's
like the message
yeah literally the headline is you don't
need to be productive during this time
yeah I think I think what people trying
to do there is not not put people in a
position of anxiety right so I think a
much better word would be anxious versus
productive I think productive is such a
positive word you know whether you're
productive on your mental health whether
you're productive on your physical
health you know I'm getting my I'm
getting my muscles going there this time
you know are you are you I think people
I think a lot of people get happiness
from being productive in their work you
know listen I think the toughest this is
why putting out content so hard we're in
a headline reading culture right and
even I can write 16 sentences other the
video I make and I can soften the title
I put the video on people are
immediately like oh that's what you know
people have to say so my hope is that
when you double-click you don't have to
be productive what it's really talking
about is like look take a breath don't
push yourself to anxiety don't burn
yourself out during this time everyone's
kind of at a snail's still at the same
token I think it's dangerous to put
people in the position of like I'm
helpless and can a bigger force help me
out of this or take care of me I think
it leads to entitlement and lack of
accountability which often leads to
great unhappiness so I I hope that
people are filtering it properly that's
how I see it a liqu s-- okay yeah that's
that's pretty much what I was thinking
you're gonna say
we kind of hear from the man himself if
this is such a subjective term to me
there's so many different ways people to
be productive it's not busting your ass
building website you know there's a
there's a very clear you know grouping
of like how do we find balance between
hard work and lack of burnout and I
think that's powerful and for me listen
as much as I love hard work and I do
listen I just haven't seen it I haven't
seen the person that's made it that
didn't put in hard work I just haven't
seen it I've seen people inherit money
and have money but they didn't make it
you know and so and by the way most of
those people end up unhappy because they
didn't make it so I think it's important
to be productive and happy and satisfied
that comes in a lot of different ways
some people go to India for 14 days and
meditate other people write for nine
hours a day with a glass of wine going
this time I think it needs to be very
personal I think balance is the key but
I don't think we should demonize how
hard work in the same way that we
shouldn't demonize meditation and
passiveness this is a self-awareness
game that was it man I think I think you
said it nailed it productivity should be
personal that was it that was hoping for
a man so that's all I really had stay
well brother taking yourself speaking
about wine wine Texas Lit I don't know
if we have a wine tech spanner
Dustin yeah uh-huh you guys are on it
I'm telling you right now with my dad I
don't see him I'm telling you right now
if you are not on this wine Tech's game
if you were buying wine anywhere else on
the internet I'm I don't know I got some
I got beef with you we might have to
meet at the flagpole 3:30 after school
and [ __ ] fight punching people in the
face this is the [ __ ] thing in
today's is bonkers just make sure
today's is absolutely insanity complete
insanity so here's the question for
Twitter and everybody actually here's a
fun little break here's the question
let's go macro for a second forget white
X get that off the board macro whine
question what is your favorite wine
please reply hashtag garyvee on Twitter
suggest them for wine texts and others
can find it what is your favorite wine
so I can start bringing more of that -
wine text all right let's keep it going
Desa let's draw people's comments for
10:15 what's good it's going really well
I love your shirt I love it
what's your name I'm zinc akash whites
they're some real pleasure of
professional Waterman a world champion
Waterman published author and you know
when I was thinking about question that
I asked you what what time is it that
called it's well it's 3:00 in the
morning yeah you know what this is what
I want to say all the people that are
hitting me up on Twitter in California
and Oregon and Washington Arizona and
crying about 6 a.m.
look at this man look at this man's
commitment is a late late call for me I
went out night diving how the collecting
some food for the family because as you
know a lot of stores are shutting down
here and that's on another no man would
keep the spirits up at this point
because of the question I had for you
Gary was something that uh you know I've
been I was thinking you know maybe
unique and that's uh what does happiness
mean to you and how do you balance
personal success and financial success
and do you see yourself as as having a
healthy balance of mind body and spirit
you know you you're a big inspiration to
me Gary I'll follow you and a lot of
your your posts throughout the social
media platforms and um yeah and that's
of question I appreciate Brendon I
appreciate it so mind body and spirit so
bill that so until six years ago my body
definitely not and I really got serious
about health and fitness on that level
on the mind and happiness side for sure
this thing has been the driving force
for me forever for me definition of
happiness is the ability to do what you
want to do everyday which is just a
remarkable gift which is why I want so
many more people to go into their
passion and not worry about making a
million dollars but but worry about
making a million smiles in their
lifetime right to me the definition
this for me is leaving a legacy so much
of my passion you know there's so many
contemporaries I have an entrepreneur
land who have no interest in producing
any content zine in doing any mentoring
and it's so foreign to me they'd rather
they'd rather build empires continuously
for themselves and the people associated
with them which I respect cuz I'm I
absolutely have that year in me but for
me I'd be so unhappy if I didn't do tea
with Gary B for free if I didn't put out
all the content if I didn't try to leave
a legacy if I didn't live a world where
I was getting emails from kids that were
inspired and started stuff I have so
much happiness inside of me that I feel
you know this is to shoot it straight
we're using a balance between gratitude
and even guilt you know I understand
that the chemicals I was given were
right I understand the circumstances
have been being an immigrant were right
which made me hungry I you don't get to
pick your parents I won that game so you
know it's really hard for me to not have
a level of like wow I have to give back
and I honestly giving back financially
once you make it is the easy part if you
can afford it writing a cheque you know
I'm proud of the things I've been doing
during this time I keep that stuff quiet
but punchline its buying you know tens
of thousands of masks and donating them
comes a little bit easier when you can
afford it it's putting the time and
right now I have a lot of fires I have a
very intense day today big
responsibilities and maintaining
people's jobs and growing the company
but but I feel compelled to give these
two hours every morning because as
stressed as I am and as much as the gray
hairs are coming in doing this kind of
time I I know that in these two hours a
lot of good is being done there's a lot
of people that need my energy right now
I can feel it and so I [ __ ] have to
do it man that's right you guys question
that actually hits home with me as well
you know I was a professional athlete
even mentioned as well you know that
balance between guilt and you said the
balance gratitude skill and gratitude
and you know my grandmother always
inspired me to live life with the
attitude of gratitude and then
but I I think I think it i think
gratitude it's gratitude and compassion
and empathy can become bigger cooler
words you know I think we can really win
this game we just need a lot more
kindness in our society there's so much
judgment and there's so much triggering
to to blame there's so much anxiety and
a lot of that comes from actual
entitlement if we were grateful for what
we had versus you know envious of what
we don't have and the things that people
Envy are such [ __ ] materialistic
horseshit I wish people knew more
multimillionaires and realized how much
unhappiness is at that level if they
really knew it
they really lived it if they really
lived that anxiety and insecurity of
most not all of course they would they
would not aspire for it yeah totally I
wish you nothing but the best brother
Nick thanks for being in the comments
Gino productions big shout out to you I
see you in the YouTube comments chart
Carter great to see you Shalom Karsten
Paulina why thank you so much for being
on YouTube with us crafty Belfast what's
good Jenelle a lot of YouTube comments
I'm feeling that a lot of Twitter
comments not as many Facebook comments
and to see the Facebook comments going
so the Facebook comments aren't coming
in because we had to set it up as like a
custom channel so the platform doesn't
recognize it as being Facebook but I'm
gonna I'm gonna figure it out moving
forward that way yeah yeah alright mr.
top floor what's good Chloe hi how are
you good things are you um well my
question it's kind of like balancing I
want to know your perspective on dance
balancing running a business and my
passion which is writing I wrote a book
I kind of shopped it around I had some
interest ultimately got rejected and
any really great advice on my rejection
letter but instead of like pulling down
there um which which I think would have
been the natural kind of response
instead I went all in on my business and
I now run the digital kind of marketing
agency where I help out writers actually
which I'm very passionate about it
fulfills me um I have one full-time
person working for me and five other
part-time and I don't know I just I
don't know when I sit down to write I
think about business and my business is
booming like people are reading more
books now and I picked up two new
clients since this whole pandemic has
started so I'm in a really good spot and
I don't know I just I don't know what
you think I listen to yourself all the
time and I was like what would Gary say
in this situation um
about kind of balancing those two I
would do them both and I would be okay
with if I'm in a moment in my business
that I go all-in for 87% on the business
and 13 on writing on the side or even by
the way a hundred you know my great love
in business is Wine Library it was my
first love
it was my family business I went super
hard and then I left and started
vaynermedia and during that time
especially the first years three four
five six and seven of vaynermedia I
really went all in on vaynermedia
because you're wanting to I still had
too many responsibilities how to make
sure Brandon and my dad were good I'm
one library without me because I was
really the leader there and and then you
know a year ago I just missed it I
missed wine commerce and I invented wine
texts you know and I for my dad and so
you might be able to write in three
years I think when people make people
make the mistake and they think balance
is a daily thing balance is a life thing
it's a it's your whole life you're such
a young woman like you might be able to
build your business up right now to so
much stability and save money that you
might be able to in eleven years to take
two years off and write your [ __ ]
novel I guess people good I don't know I
fear that if I let it go for too long
it'll just be it and just passions don't
die
passions are your best friend they're
sitting there waiting for you whenever
you come
they are they're your best friends
they're always there sports cards have
been there wine have been there you know
seven years ago I went all garyvee 100%
built a humongous company have nothing
but opportunity could go on and do all
sorts of things and Here I am you know
at forty four and two of the biggest
things I talk about are wine and sports
cards my passions from when I was
fifteen to things that were not coming
out of my mouth at all three years ago
four years ago through the year I have a
funny feeling if you look at all my
content three and four years ago I'm not
sure if there's a single mention of wine
or baseball cards or sports cards
passions are always there they're just
sitting over there your best friend just
waiting for you to sit by the bench some
[ __ ] Forrest Gump [ __ ] I understand I
understand
balancing everybody debates on a daily
basis it's their number one mistake it's
not a daily thing that's not a weekly
thing it's not a monthly thing it's not
even a yearly thing it is a full life
thing your business is rocking right now
it's okay to go 100 percent in for
thirty six months I promise you pen and
paper laptop and [ __ ] Word documents
are sitting right there waiting for you
open arms with a big hug and kiss and
ready to go and by the way you'll be a
different woman at that point and you
might be able to be in a situation where
you might be even more creative yeah can
I ask you a business question then um I
interviewed someone last week to be my
second full-time person and I had kind
of started recruiting months ago before
all this happened and I found a person
that I think would do well but I don't
know now if it's the time to take on a
full-time staff like I said things are
moving up for me but I don't know I
think as long as you over communicate
with her like hey things are moving up
for me but it's uncertain anything could
happen
I don't want to screw you this is not
the most stable situation plus I'm a
small company and give her the right to
choose for him you know where did you
get your clarity from you know what's
funny I actually think besides natural
DNA and I always think I was born with
wisdom I do think I'm an old soul I was
very attracted to older people when I
was little I would always hang out with
like grandmas and grandpas on the
playground in New York and New Jersey
besides that I actually think it's a
little bit of a lack of education I'm
not even kidding
I think that I so didn't conform to the
school system and I so didn't pay
attention starting in third grade that I
was just in my own [ __ ] world and I
think in some weird ways that simplicity
has been a huge guiding light I keep it
basic as [ __ ] and we all appreciate you
so much for that thank you so much well
take care of yourself big shout-out to
viola Jay on YouTube
ginger beloved Facebook people if you
want to get your comments shout it out
or pinned you can switch over to Twitter
or YouTube live lots of comments coming
through there Andrew what's up Brad
rotor what's good Eli Murphy what is
good I don't make money as a middle
school or during this quarantine Eli say
sell every single thing in your room on
eBay and Facebook market please Chris
it's really good it's good to see you
you were talking about seven eight years
ago and like check that out that was a
video you made me seven almost eight
years ago when I had a tiny tiny little
office and you talk about documenting
here we are eight years later I'm gonna
ask you a question about like a national
company I have and a lot of that is is
you and so first of all thank you very
much
getting right down to it business owners
this is for like the leadership people
that are following you the people that
follow you eight years ago that now you
know if they've listened they've got
kind of something so it's a difficult
time with the pandemic and everything
else like what advice do you give to
leaders like myself with not only not
only keeping like the synergy of a team
intact but also morale everything else
because like employees think of them
layoffs Financial Times everything else
what's your advice to the leaders out
here
communication and clarity literally at
11 o'clock I go on with a 20-person call
of 20 liters of Vayner give them the
update of what I see this week and then
at 11:30 today I go and address the
entire organization on livestream for 30
minutes and I'm gonna tell them the
truth
lots of optimism lots of opportunity and
lots of unsettling lack of data and when
you don't have good information it's
hard to make good decisions and a lot of
a lot of issues at our client level you
know bankruptcies payment delays lots of
stuff mercury mercury mercury and so I'm
gonna try to find the balance of
inspiration and transparency which is
very difficult because most people will
not hear the inspiration they'll hear
the fear if I lead to anything like some
of our clients might go out of business
and this you know immediately everyone's
like I'm getting fired so you know I'm
worried about that so I'm gonna try to
find that balance I'm gonna dress that
on right I'm gonna speak to that you
know at some point I'm gonna say
something that's just transparent and
then I'm gonna feel it and say guys I
know you're sending it right now in your
house you're like uh that means whatever
you Jillian listen if you're great
you're fine
if you're contributing you're fine you
know obviously we'll have to look at the
reality situation but you know I've been
looking at how much we pay for bananas
and how much we pay for candles and how
much we pay for cleaning our offices to
do anything I can possibly do to save
jobs that is my number one priority and
and I just have to speak that truth yeah
that that's never talked about right how
efficient our businesses come when you
suddenly have to look at it in a
different perspective right it's yeah no
matter how much no matter how you know
frugal you are no matter how CFO driven
you are there's always an opportunity to
cut more costs always are you still
getting the words in I am pretty good
I've been working out every day mike is
a Mike and I are teleconferencing end on
FaceTime on laptop I've been feeling
pretty good about that
I'm pretty good about that and I'm up
for this challenge like it's super
painful a friend of mine said a good
analogy
they about if you have to let people go
it's like being in the forests and tree
falls on your leg and whoever Park rings
just like look you're gonna die if you
don't we don't cut off your leg and and
you know you cut off your leg and you
[ __ ] love your leg like there's
nobody you you don't want to let go of
anybody right now but if but if you
can't make payroll then the whole thing
dies if you can't pay your bills your
dad or whatever it might be for people
and so this is real life so look with
the event and you know you've got to be
a professional a lot of people have
small businesses and don't have overhead
and they need to just be more humble in
their own lives and then other people
like ourselves have a lot of employees
and you got to look at everything so you
everything you've always talked about
the right if you're just real if you're
human and you're keeping them informed I
found I talked to the management team
last week the other in the other brands
and it was just like if you're having
those conversations they're you're
bringing those fears to light in a good
way you know what I mean like a good way
yeah your people inform they know what
might happen and yeah anyways man I
appreciate you we were you we were
supposed to connect in Edmonton but then
I got cancelled I'm coming back though
Edmonton is not going to be fully
canceled it's put that one's postponed I
will be in Edmonton that is fantastic
thanks for you see that Chris hey well
love you back
Chris I'm known for a long time in
social Thomas good to see you Chris be
thank you for watching Barry Stella
thank you for making this your first tee
time Dustin let's throw up a bunch of a
bunch of people's comments on the screen
people like that little moment 5 5 SEC 5
7 seconds I'm fine with it just
rapid-fire a lot of people yeah they go
by really quick so I'm trying not to hit
like the ones that say like let's go
what I mean by can't hear it if you
don't know me is don't get too high
don't get too low with comments Anthony
what's good hey Gary
um I can't believe I'm talking to you
right now it's crazy so just to give you
a little bit of clarity I'm a twitch
streamer I'm actually using my setup
right now
I've been streaming on Twitch for the
last 2 years I started Wells and
school and I kind of like threw myself
back into it I'm getting more serious
with it as of the last six months and
that lately I've just been doing it
every day I've been having like
incrementals incremental success with a
few follows here and there and a couple
subs and I'm really happy about it like
I mean I get excited but I just kind of
wanted to ask you how do I differentiate
myself between like other streamers
maybe that are small or bigger like I
feel like it's not but of course it's
saturated and it should be so as YouTube
influence of course it should be it's a
free platform where you can do what you
[ __ ] love and make money the world
saturated brother okay and what's like
oh Gary tic TOCs now saturate them like
yep which is saturated now yeah it's
supposed to be the the way to
differentiate is to be a hundred percent
you I'll give you a huge piece advice
don't watch a single other screamer
really really okay I mean I because what
ends up happening is you subconsciously
start taking some of their flavor and
then you just start looking like
everybody else I think one of the
reasons I don't look like anybody else
is because I don't consume anybody else
and I don't I I think a lot of people
are different than me and are really
good at looking at other people and
taking good value from them so I don't
think it's a 100 percent all-or-nothing
thing but I think most people need to
start getting to a place where they
consume other people less so they can
find their own [ __ ] voice okay I mean
I I don't like for instance I don't know
if you know who Nick mercs is but like I
do okay I watch him but I don't compare
myself I'm more or less watching because
he's really good at like shooters and
like iPod I get that that that's that's
you I respect that and it's not like you
should not use it for entertainment my
concern is that you know anytime you
start comparing to anybody else big or
small it gets into this competitive most
people are in this game of like worrying
about numbers and worrying about tactics
and I'm concerned about that whereas
what I really think will actually break
you out is being yourself telling
stories about who you are while you're
playing like [ __ ] how you got how you
beat up Ricky Thompson in third grade
like it's storytelling it
comes down to connecting with the
audience and I think that that's what
you need to focus on like you need to
show more of yourself the only
competitive advantage we all have is our
unique stories us okay I'm I mean you I
think you've said this before that like
anytime you're a content creator it's
between or like with twitch streaming
it's between you're either really good
at the game or you're funny like those
are the two things that kinda hurt or
you can be kind of funny and kind of
good and a hundred percent you and
[ __ ] dominate
okay I guess my follow-up question is
that because because funny is happening
now no different than dancing on
tick-tock but I promise you
somebody's about to go on Twitch and be
a psychologist while they play and
[ __ ] bring mindset to kids bro I
don't I'm not good at games
I'm telling right now if I start playing
old-school Nintendo [ __ ] that was decent
at and [ __ ] old Sega Genesis but
[ __ ] start a drop in knowledge for
three hours for the kids I'd have a
humongous twitch channel sure that's
true so you just need to be you like
talk about what you know talk about real
life talk about your heart getting
broken talk about why your uncle
inspires you talk about like you know
why you're impressed by Booga winning
the [ __ ] for a night or like talk
about [ __ ] okay not more
all right I mean I'm trying to like you
know teach myself Adobe Premiere so I
can like put out more videos and stuff
actually been talking
everything is phenomenal go ahead okay
so I mean I've been trying to put out
more stuff but the follow-up question
was I feel like should I even try to
look for that net like that next big
game to get good at to then try and like
yeah that's like in in in eSports
that's like tick-tocking and Instagram
and YouTube if you catch the next big
game and you're [ __ ] G at it it's
gonna [ __ ] matter absolutely I think
that's a good use of time okay because
I've been looking up aura and stuff and
yeah alright but you have listened why
am I always early and winning every
snapchat Facebook it's because I'm not
scared everybody brings up tick-tock and
and Facebook and Twitter nobody breaks
up the two months I wasted on plurk
nobody talks about the three months I
wasted on social cam nobody talks about
the five months I wasted on photo booth
or dailybooth
excuse me I'm not scared
if a new game came out call Jackson
arrows and I got [ __ ] gnarly at it
but nobody gave a [ __ ] I wouldn't do
well that I spent seven months getting
great at [ __ ] jacks and arrows true
everyone's [ __ ] scared of wasting
time when their [ __ ] time ain't worth
[ __ ]
it's called entitlement everybody's
fancy thinks they're special like why
are you wearing why are people worried
about [ __ ] wasting time when they're
actually investing to Chris Kim's point
in understanding [ __ ] because by the way
the time I wasted on [ __ ] dailybooth
and [ __ ] Socialcam is the reason I
[ __ ] understood vine snapchat IG TV
tick tock hmm so that uh okay so then if
you moved it over to games if that Jack
game you just talked about the mechanics
can still be transferred over like oh
you still are good at shooting in the
Jack game you can still be good at
shooting in this other game now oh my
god that clicked holy [ __ ]
all I'm trying to do is eliminate fear
people are scared of wasting time when
their time there's I mean I can't I mean
the entitlement and the audacity that
comes along with like I don't wanna
waste my time
[ __ ] are you doing otherwise jerk damn
Gary [ __ ] what's your twitch handle I
want to make sure everybody gets to
watch oh this is RK so th is is is and
then RK are there a are CH e AR CH e yes
sure
say some what see yeah thank you that
was a good one
team Gary V let's chop that one there's
something there I want that as an IG TV
ASAP oh don't even test it
get some headlines let's [ __ ] go hey
Gary hey Megan how are you good
I just want to say shout-out to you for
making me self-aware enough to know that
I am not meant to be a number one on any
day of the week but I do I do make a
kick-ass number 2 so I leaned into that
pretty hard so I work with a creative
real estate investor and our goal is to
make creative real estate investing a
tool for everyone to build wealth and we
leave with people first because we truly
do believe it is a people business so
our question to you is how can we become
a national real estate icon and scale in
order to support that content ok so I
have a question when it comes to content
cuz I was like I we have trouble kind of
breaking down difficult topics into
small consumable pieces because that's
because the person who's communicating
is long-winded ok so what is the best
way you can kind of give us to break
down a complicated topic into a you know
a fourth grade or fifth grade level
understanding decks are good I don't
know if you've ever seen my content if
you last for everybody's watching Google
Gary Vee content deck it will help a lot
of use of decks are good
cartoons animations what I'm worried
listen humans do it I take complex's
[ __ ] stuff and really break it down to
first grade level right you just you
just might have a long-winded
communicator
I'm just which is okay rather that that
person can train to get tighter and more
concise or you find somebody else as a
human being to consume it seem easy to
communicate it awesome okay cool no that
makes that makes sense so when we're
building a brand do you recommend having
it be under a personal name so like
let's just say Megan or under okay both
where'd you do both at the same time
feel like when you do like a niche
specific business name and your personal
make sure Steve Jobs is a brand Apple is
a plant right both can work it just
comes down to the human and it comes
down to the business so when it comes to
finding people to make the animations
would you just recommend a normal like
fiber or something like that or up work
because we haven't having trouble trying
to find people to make the animations
and the drawings so if anybody does that
they say your Twitter handle let people
hit you up which is at Cory J Calvin
spell it cor Y J CA L VI n I love it
yeah guess what guess what you just
found an animator
thank you I'm super excited Dustin do a
nice work there is the actual handle
mega thank you so much for calling in
thank you Gary
all right let's see what's going on here
more comments magic Brad what's good
thank you for watching mr. top floor
what's good Chris Vargas appreciate it
elementary flips if you want your
question on the show please hit me up on
two one two nine three one five seven
three one two and two nine three one
five seven three one let's do it
Clem how are you hey I'm fine thank you
are you from I was pretty excited to be
I'm from Austria so a Central Europe by
the way I also started in wine I'm a
banker well by training and I did all of
that to follow my passion which is this
thing behind me so a while back I can
tinkering with electronics mostly and
now I made that helping my job and a few
days ago I turned Freddy free and I said
to myself why not gift myself the
company that I would also like to start
so I make a second venture because like
my my own brand is totally dependent on
me so I can't source anything out I have
to do it myself but I want to grow that
and maybe employ people someday so I got
a new hobby this is an RCS controller
yeah it's pretty much a competition
thing and that's get it's getting really
popular currently and also people are
building them in the current team
currently and so I made a little
invention so you see the the chassis
that's my design and I also fabricate
these things so I'm trying to take not
really advantage but I'm trying to
encourage people to not spend more money
than they could afford on such a machine
that one is designed to be extremely
variable and so people can use used and
old parts to build new competition legal
machines so they can have fun on a
budget so and I want to launch that
later that year but first I want to
create a lot of content around this
because it's a product that you need to
explain a lot and now I mean the should
I spent a lot of time and effort and
obviously also money on making a
juggernaut of content that is ready on
launch or should I use only the the main
things and feel out what people want
number two I would be putting out
content as often as possible to get
feedback because if you spend a lot of
time money and energy on a ton of
content that nobody sees you're not
using the Internet's feedback loop to
get smarter you're you're using a 1985
model you know in the same way that
you're innovating on the chassis I want
you to innovate on content no reason to
do it like they used to do it and guess
you
to be putting out content every day and
seeing the feedback and getting a sense
of what really resonates it's really
cool that this is popping and I I know
this has been getting more and more
popular in Europe in general and it was
very big in the u.s. in the early 90s my
big shout out to my friend Robbie turn
ik-hee I remember he had a car and I
remember a lot of people were getting
into it to be interesting to see how
global this gets and how much this will
play into the u.s. or Asia but I think
you're in a very interesting niche that
has a ton of opportunity it's I think
because the regulations on RC flying
which I was into before got so strong
and so restrictive that you're not
basically not allowed to go anywhere to
fly it so I have to travel about a
hundred kilometres to be legally able to
fly so I prep those and focused on the
crawlers so as you'll be you choose you
know yes what if I'm working for an
American YouTube channel called
element14 presents so that's a channel
that around revolves around electronics
then is where I get my money at my
project fundings I close down my own
little channel to focus on that and of
course I will do a new channel probably
called train back like the company nice
yeah and do a lot of content there and I
also have the opportunity to get a
property where I can legally film which
is also an issue and build like a
training facility there to have events
and film out of people's cars their
hands and maybe even have my own racing
team that I with drivers that I know us
with my products super smash I think you
had a good yeah I think you're well on
your way
I like everything that's coming down
there now I think you need to put out
more content on tik-tok and Instagram
daily daily yeah is there is there
something that you think that would
specifically work well on those
platforms I'm not sure but you need to
test it doesn't that even if I even if I
fully did you'd still have to interpret
it and make it you have to make you have
to make
in the same way that you tinkered to
figure it out you need to tinker with
content yeah hot fing in the same way
that it's impossible for me to do what
you do right it's hard like I'm not
handy I don't want to [ __ ] put a
picture on the wall let alone build a
[ __ ] chair yeah chassis [ __ ] that you
know but so I get it so maybe so maybe
you take some money and you hire you
hire an intern who she or he is very
passionate about making content yeah
that would be a thing not more the maker
I get it I get it yeah when you can't do
it bringing somebody in at a low cost
there's so many people that are passion
about making content by the way there's
young kids in Austria specifically in
Austria let alone Europe right now who
desperately want one of your cars but
can't afford it yet they're unbelievable
at making content for the internet we
need to be thinking more about barter
you can make a video right now on your
small little youtube channel that you
close down repopulate it up even if
there's 25 people who are watching make
a video and say I will make four cars
for you which has value you make a lot
of content for me who wants to barter
who wants to trade we need a lot more
trade the Internet should bring it I see
the internet bringing back a lot of
old-school habits one of the old-school
habits long before there was money was
we were trading I raised cattle you
raised vegetables we trade you could
make a coat I could make a meal we trade
you can you're [ __ ] unbelievable of
what you do there's somebody right now
probably two miles away from you who's
unbelievable making tic TOCs and
youtubes and is enjoying what you do and
you can make that trade that's a
probably a finger first after I posted
the first prototypes like the first one
was in Inwood so I could cut in on my
little laser just in Dane and I
immediately somebody said will you sell
them can I get them somewhere so that
initially go into that okay content and
if you can't do it find somebody who can
and either pay them or trade them yeah
take care
rrrow he said you got an extra hundred
subscribers I wonder if he's talking to
about that uh channel is on let's see
let's just tender I love people so much
my stretches with the [ __ ] with the
haha I love your little shrine back
there bro I see your content on Twitter
I always appreciate you thank you thank
you for everything I'm gonna keep it
short and sweet even though you're busy
um you know I'm sterile real estate my
client I had a super successful year
last year thank you so much for
everything thank you for allowing me to
leave my day job um I'm bit in front of
my clients but I want to try to start to
tell them hey this is how you save your
house or you may have to downsize I've
had clients who bought huge homes
smaller homes I don't know if everybody
is still working or not how do I
approach that conversation without being
such like doom and gloom is there like a
way to do it with your with your former
clients to check in on where they're at
is that what you're asking
yeah I've been checking in but I have it
I haven't broke the hey how are you
financially um I think I think a nice
way to do it is potentially sending
everybody chocolate flowers wine with a
note that says hey it's me just trying
to brighten up your day during this time
and I'm here for any conversation
professionally that you need let me know
I think that that's a way to put in a
deposit on a twenty thirty fifty dollar
investment on somebody on the other side
and a sweet way to do it and if you
really write pay just sending you to
this nice bottle of empathy you know
because I've got empathy during this
situation speak in which if you uh if
you uh if there's anything I could talk
to you about professionally if you need
me in any way on business here's my
number I think it would work yeah
because what I've been doing I always
sent out like the holiday cards and
whatever people want that [ __ ] you know
what that [ __ ] real life now because
well I actually think they want some
stuff like right now people sitting at
home ding dong FedEx after they wipe it
down they're scared for a day or two if
they open it up and there's a bottle
wine if there's flowers if there's
chocolate-covered pretzels like that's a
nice thing to do
okay so on your other site your site for
your for the store does that deliver
also besides I can get the treats
delivered as well
oh yeah and by the way you know wines
complicated obviously empathy can ship
everywhere Wine Library wine techs can't
there's also by the way alcohol is like
you know wines a seventy percent thing I
think I think chocolates a seventy
percent thing I think flowers is an
eighty percent thing plus go back to
your memory bank and remember some of
the [ __ ] that you were talking about
with those people maybe you remember
that they're a Minnesota Vikings fan and
you sent him something like that so just
be creative and thoughtful okay I do
think I do think I do think empathy
ironically we're in the up of yet I do
think empathy I gotta talk the empathy
team I do think the I'm empathy during
this time kind of like transition and no
card is kind of fresh anyway go ahead
if you things to buy with that cuz the
branding is awesome for that weekend not
yet um you know I'm a big fan of like
settling the base I want to go down the
wine brand oh you did I'm sorry can
everybody ask to me Dustin you can hear
me okay yeah I could still hear you I
can hear you you can hear me okay
no race not yet brother but we're
working on it okay
I just couldn't hear you I'm sorry no
race thank you I will do thank you you
got it really long game life what's good
Dustin I see uh I see a a barbershop
with eight locations in Jersey teen Gary
let's get that person to the queue for
tomorrow's tea with Gary Vee
cool same with Lord
Adam Lord Adam on on YouTube assassin a
good question
Lord Adam if you can go to Twitter ask
that question or team whoever's
community managing YouTube right now hit
up Lord Adam let's get him into the
queue for Wednesday or Thursday
Preston hey Gary how are you I'm well
man thank you so much for all the
Twitter interaction haven't seen you a
lot oh yeah well it's been fun thanks
for having me on my heart is racing
right now this is super cool I really
appreciate it
thank you what are you from by the way I
live in Atlanta born and raised
I saw John Abraham's you know a huge fan
of that money laughs I loved him he was
literally one of my favorites of all
time yeah yeah he professed that turning
in dollars another big favorite of mine
for Falcons a really good person oh cool
so um again really appreciate it been
funny for a couple years so a little bit
of background I just started a health
care company a medical device company
selling surgical products to hospitals
so as you can imagine in this time the
last you know month or so we really
haven't been able to do a lot especially
on the sales friend you know you call a
hospital for all the right reasons they
don't have time to talk about anything
and we don't have what they are needing
in this current time so as a result of
that we've stopped all of our sales
activities because we don't want to be
bothering them yeah absolutely so my
question is you know instead of just
hitting the pause button on everything
for months to months however long you
know what can we be doing in terms of
either building community you know
building our brand without being tone
deaf I don't want to be pushing out tons
and tons of stuffs I got it yeah I got I
think it's I think it's storytelling
around you and the journey of how you
got there you've heard that for me I
know you're paying attention I'm a big
fan of leveling up in facebook groups so
I think starting a Facebook group that
might be called like Atlanta
entrepreneurs is not a horrible idea
or or Atlanta
health and wellness professionals you
know like creating a Facebook group and
taking all your channels and energy and
trying to build up that group and then
starting you know once you get 50 people
into that group starting a nightly zoom
or hangout or steam yard
with 10 15 20 people like there's a you
know those kind of thing or see there's
a little bit but like zooms and Google
Hangouts where you can do happy hours
and just shoot the [ __ ] I would become a
bigger local presence okay because you
understand the the hospital
professionals are not gonna join that
cuz their busiest [ __ ] but when that
doctor is married to a guy who has a
landscaping business and he's part of
the group when he like loves you because
you were the [ __ ] creator of the
group and he's your homie and when it's
all over in August when you have dinner
in Buckhead with him and his wife who
happens to be a [ __ ] doctor or a lead
person in hospital you see how it works
yeah people people say no because they
don't see the chess move they only see
the move in front of them and like I'm
not starting a Facebook group all the
[ __ ] Hospital professionals that I
want are [ __ ] tied up I'm like right
and that's why I get to be me and you
get to be you well you're not thinking
about is hey the Karma putting together
a nice group which is you know be is the
reality is it's just really nice to
[ __ ] do that kind of karma stuff get
friends things that nature and then see
most of all humans are connected to
humans literally a dentist is gonna join
your group is gonna be on a zoom is
gonna meet up once we can meet in real
you know you're gonna have this group
that you get together with every two
nights for cocktails well you know
what's gonna happen July 19 they're all
gonna get together in real life and the
dentist is literally single best friends
went to Georgia Tech with the [ __ ]
head of [ __ ] mount this mount that
hospital X and you're [ __ ] on your way
people aren't to teach ik people aren't
patient people aren't kind people aren't
willing to give with nothing in return
people aren't patient to let it play
relationships play out for three years
and people aren't strategic they don't
even see it so I'm [ __ ] dropping
knowledge right now pressing that's the
real thing yeah Chris guess yeah it's
better than sitting around yeah
that I mean that makes a lot of sense
I've been certainly guessed more on you
know the hospital people work in health
care you know let's chess yes when we
first start I want to put out like a lot
of educational kind of things you know
but this is a unique time when PBS stuck
and starting uh entrepreneurs helping
entrepreneurs in Atlanta group would be
a really good idea right now yeah and by
the way for the tens of thousands people
that are watching just replace the word
Atlanta with Birmingham or Louisville or
Salt Lake City or [ __ ] Aspen and away
you go
host the virtual party during this time
become the head of the Chamber of
Commerce become the mayor virtually of
the Entrepreneurship community by
starting a Facebook group using all your
other channels email text people like
Carrie but I don't have a lot of social
media followers I'm like you have an
address book they're like yeah I'm like
start at a and with the Z and and text
people the URL to the Facebook you can
say yo you want to join this and then
once you get 19 or 23 the virality
starts kicking in okay yeah a nice a lot
of sense if it guys you Lord quick so I
I'm pretty super active on Linkedin a
lot of like health care things you
personally have a said like a LinkedIn
page for the the company and just sort
of like a small tactical thing I I'm in
the comments of people all the time
sharing you know I thought leaders
things like that for the company I mean
we post and we put out articles things
like that as a company do you typically
like jump in comments like interact the
same way that is this yeah and and you
can do the logo of the company and then
at the end of your comment you could be
- Preston Alexander okay got it
yeah perfect awesome awesome good yeah
thanks well [ __ ] given out tactics
what a first hour of tea with Gary Vee
let's go to Twitter real quick I'm just
gonna go hold on one second Destin don't
throw anybody up just gonna go to
Twitter in my own just see what's going
on here who empathy wins is heavy go in
there Craig Kaplan quick Kaplan you're
getting a follow
boom I'm 148 follow Craig I also want
you honor I also want you that's awesome
Craig my name beyond
um tea time Kyle okay Big Ups to you
brother okay right now everybody who's
watching take a screenshot of this and
post it on Twitter take a screenshot of
the next guest than me and post it on
Twitter with hashtag tea with Gary B and
put up the URL to YouTube or Facebook in
it and we'll be doing some following its
keep going Bradley hey hey what's going
on Gary oh it's good bro where you from
I'm in Cedar Falls Iowa small faster I
know it gosh it is so cool he's talking
to you oh my gosh I just I have to thank
you for something real quick you had a
IG CV post probably at least a month ago
now it was talking about I don't
remember who you were with but you were
in a room with a chick and probably like
her manager and you were talking about
like who just who - like associate with
and how to like post on social and
things like that
I don't know if you know maybe yeah
anyways you were you were talking about
like I think people associate with me
because I'm a Jets fan or people people
[ __ ] with me because I you know that
thing and that revolutionized the way
that I think about Mike I have an
advertising agency that revolutionized
the way that I think about that and the
way that I talk to my clients about how
they post on social and giving them
advice so I just want to thank you for
that I was like okay my question is I'm
a really really ambitious person and I
struggle sometimes with setting goals
that are way way too high because I I
want the world and I want it now and I I
really try and practice patience but
sometimes it's not always easy so
anyways I set these goals were really
really high and when I don't end up
hitting them because nine times at it
that's cuz you put a timeline on
true.you [ __ ] your [ __ ] child
your [ __ ] child and they wouldn't
mean you haven't hit them you're [ __ ]
you put a time limit on them there's
nothing worse than putting a time limit
on a goal there's nothing worse there's
no more guaranteed way to be sad and
anxious and get [ __ ] up than to put a
time limit on a goal
in the age to get married and aged to
have kids
and age to make your first hundred
thousand an age to retire an age to quit
job there's nothing more guaranteed in
[ __ ] yourself up then putting a time
limit on an actual goal okay okay so and
kind of to to kind of change that around
I've also tried in the past making like
really really small small goals and like
making it something that I can the
content today or like oh yeah yeah okay
gonna but then I always had like it was
like I always gonna feel like I could've
done more like I think they're effective
cuz I can stop done but I always feel
like I could have done more or I don't
feel like I was I was um like maximizing
my my efforts I'm like what I was doing
I think I think you have a really bad
relationship with time and I think if we
can hack that in the same way that we
had kind of the ideas around content I
think you can have a real breakthrough
you know like yeah to me to me
I I you just have this fascination this
need to create time frames which are
both upsetting you think about what you
just broke down
I make [ __ ] goals and I achieve them
and of course subconsciously I feel like
[ __ ] because I know if [ __ ] sandbagged
it yeah I meet these monster [ __ ]
goals that are completely unattainable
and I you just [ __ ] yourself up
you're judging yourself okay so stick
with me on this one okay this is the
most important part you're judging
yourself yeah I am you're right I am
there's no reason how do i how well easy
a we just spend time this morning thank
God for you know everybody thinks of it
as a bad thing and then they don't
realize the person that would have died
in a car accident right God rest his
soul one of my my buds
Nipsey Hussle dies a year ago during the
Cova time if cove it happened last year
he would have be alive so people people
don't see the positive you know kovat
led to me and you I wouldn't be [ __ ]
doing tee time you know here we are so
how do you do it
you take the [ __ ] gratitude and
blessing of this [ __ ] chance
encounter
where we [ __ ] zoom in on it [ __ ]
pure sabot right now you'd know it
now it's [ __ ] out there tens of
thousands of people saw it I know it you
know it best of all you know it so now
that we know it we take a step back hey
did that judgment get into my brain
because my mom and dad judged me and now
I've taken on that voice manipulated it
like a virus and it's inside of me and
do I cut it out - I clearly worry too
much about what other people think
because I'm trying to create these
arbitrary goals to flex them or to put
them on a mantle so you can see my
[ __ ] trophy you know those are the
two things that I'm best at I'm best at
not [ __ ] hearing a single thing and
not judging myself and - I have no
interest in flexagon anybody about
anything cuz I don't give a [ __ ] if you
think I'm greater I suck so you're
saying so you're so you're saying keep
the goal keep the goals out there
regardless of how or or make a monster
goal professionally yeah you know like
buying the New York Jets yes and not put
a time limit on it and realize the
reason you have that crazy goal is not
because you actually want to buy the New
York Jets it's because you love being an
entrepreneur so much that you're
creating a goal that's so far away that
you can [ __ ] play this game that you
love more than breathing for the rest of
your [ __ ] life I love that I love
that that's that's I love that that's
fantastic
what so okay that's wow that's it but I
did you're right I know on solution yeah
bad yeah no it is I
it's the recall at the beginning of this
video bro and how fun it is to start
getting these gray hairs cuz now really
understand you know it was in me at your
age at a young age but now I'm through a
lot of reps I've seen a lot of patterns
I've watched millions of people hundreds
of thousands intimately I've watched
them all I do is watch and I'm telling
you this is the [ __ ] framework okay
okay so so with because because being
happy is gonna be
way more cool than making them than
being a millionaire at 31 100 % i 100%
agree i saw that post on instagram the
other day a hundred percent that putting
a timeframe on it is making you unhappy
so have the goals regardless of how long
it takes to get done when I buy the New
York Jets I'm gonna sit in that office
room when I sign those papers or
whatever [ __ ] the virtual room where the
[ __ ] it is and I swear to [ __ ] god
even though I know the second I
announced at 48 hours later 24 hours
later an hour later the world's gonna
rejoice there's gonna be a part of me
that dies because you don't process ace
anymore that's right that's the grind
the dirt that's right the cheese you
know what I mean I do I do make make
make the timeframe forever and you'll
you'll slow down you'll be much better
behavior it'll make you a more honorable
man too cuz you're not gonna [ __ ] try
to quickly get to something and when you
want to get to something quickly your
behavior gets bad and somebody wants
something fast they start going into
darker places of you know like it's
crazy how good my behavior has become
out of patience okay okay I love that
that's that's my boy that's fantastic
Garrick I really appreciate I appreciate
you good luck team Gary be let's chop
that up I want that on your TV tomorrow
maybe even for 7:30 tonight that's
[ __ ] fire there's something really
there I don't I wasn't reading Dustin
how are the comments that was like a
moment right like the people [ __ ] get
it yeah people people love that moment
that's [ __ ] real [ __ ] I think we
helped a lot of people sure by the way
even even going meta tea with Gary Vee
is resonating with people because I have
more time I'm not people hate me when I
do podcast interviews cuz I forty
minutes I gotta get them out that's the
other person I'm interrupting
interrupting disrupting askgaryvee he's
an hour they call in I know I want to
get one or two more but this two hours
has given me a little bit of a pacing
that's a lid just just an inch you know
shower lets me to be really sure
allows people to finish their thoughts a
little bit better time let's keep it
going hey how are you I can't hear you
can't hear you
no we still can't hear you
we're gonna I'll keep you on yeah get
her fixed up yep Gary how are you hated
hey thank you so much for having me on
I'm so happy I'm getting emotional
you taught me so much thank you are you
from Arizona
how have I helped you sorry dude it's
all right dude it's super right I
appreciate it so much you don't even
know how warm my body feels right now
thank you for that so my question is you
my dad have a flooring company company
flooring so carpet tile understood oh
jeez I'm so embarrassed but it's all me
bearish bro all right he's a strength so
we we started at three years ago my
dad's been doing it forever um so like
that's part of the reason why I relate
cuz like you work with your dad you guys
you did what you did anyways we've been
scaling we've been growing like we hit
like last year we did a million and a
half and revenue and so we were happy
about that I just graduated college last
year
so anyways now that I have more time
because I was working full-time I did 60
credit hours last year I've started
running more ads and doing more with our
digital marketing stuff yeah and it's
been blowing up Facebook's been killing
it for us as important like I've always
said ya know I'm super deep into your
content I picked up crushing it two or
three years ago in it that
really did it for me I was it was
awesome and that's crazy because like
you said you never know what type of
content is gonna that's gonna hit deep
and it was crushing it for me anyways my
question is like we've started to
acquire leads at a very efficient rate
we've been blowing up on Facebook it's
been well there's no complaint there my
question is is how do we continue to
scale and handle all of these leads
hiring so I mean my dad obviously he's
my dad and you know he he kind of when I
say that I'm like dad we just need to
hire like we just need to trust people
we need to give him a chance we need to
do it and he's always like slow down yep
this is where he gets emotional cuz you
know what's right for the business and
you love your pops and it's and and
there's a line in the sand there and
it's super hard you're gonna have to
fight I mean I would I'll never be able
to explain how much pushing I did to get
my dad to do things
my dad's actual natural reaction to
everything on earth is no mine is yes
and that is a very different framework
you've got to make your dad have the
conversation
you can't stop when he says slow down
let's let's roleplay I'm like but dad if
we hire them if it doesn't work out and
we can't afford it or if they steal from
us we can fire them yeah but we're not
ready to hire more people but we are dad
I have so many leads coming in that were
actually now losing money by not hiring
someone not the reverse
well you I know don't be you be him what
will he say to that yeah but we don't
have the right analytics in place to
know if we're making money or we're not
making money off of these these sales
people but Dad what we what we need to
worry about is the macro not the micro
you're overanalyzing the analytics we
don't need those tools if at the end of
the year this
we knew 2.3 instead of 1.5 and our
overhead only went up by 200,000 that's
net positive dad yeah but let's take it
slowly I mean we can hire another
salesman or two in a couple months
dad I believe in this so much that I'm
willing not to get paid for two months
to four months if you let me hire one
person so I can show you ready so ready
let's do this go there with him let's
see what he does with that and if he
actually calls your bluff good news
we've actually hired four salesmen since
the beginning of the year and that's
yeah that's what helped us really really
handle all these leads and we've had a
really really good quarter so far it
sounds like so it does sound like dad is
supporting offense he is but it's it's a
hybrid offensive defense because I'm
super aggressive and I'm ambitious and I
like to work hard and we like we both
like to go after it but he's more
defensive in and sometimes he's like
hold on hold on that's that's because
he's been through oh wait that's because
he's been through a one that's because
he's been through some [ __ ] actually I'm
really happy kovetz happening for you
because you can see what he's talking
about now yet it looks like you haven't
been affected yet to your is what I
heard from you um
look listen family businesses is a give
and take
why not you've change the script up on
me a little bit in a good way with your
pop how many salespeople did you have
before January we had like one or two
and they're kind of rotating in and out
but because now you yeah and now you
have four full-time yeah I get pops a
lot of credit that's a lot of offense
and so maybe you want it to be seven
like I don't know if I ever got until
until it really got going those first
three four five six years I didn't ever
have a hundred percent of what I wanted
ever you know I also was ambitious and
hungry and all that I think I think
there is a responsibility of the child
to have respect for the person that
started it from zero
which then comes in the form of getting
40 to 80% of what you want you know and
if you want 9 I'm I'm I'm pretty okay
with the for you know what you can do in
that that scenario is look there's so
many ways to do this in that scenario
what you can do is refine your skills in
your lead gen because please look so
good people don't have any different
pieces of creative you guys have so I
mean I'm posting at least one to three
times a day so that's organic on the
fanpage or you're doing ads yeah and so
what I do is then I take my ads because
I take pictures of jobs that we do with
our guys working and installing and then
I put those on our Facebook page and our
other social media platforms and then I
take those posts and I create them with
ads in mind and then I start running ads
against those how many how much creative
do you think you're running in that at
the Arizona area
how many did the Facebook post do you
think you have of ads yeah like
different pictures because you could
have the same picture going to four
different segmentations like okay into
the nitty-gritty now like how many
different pictures so I do like four out
of time and I do campaign budget
optimization and it just goes off it
goes crazy how much video no zero
because I don't know what type of video
content to create you didn't know what
pictures to create at first either yeah
okay video content for a flooring
company go what do you do good news your
[ __ ] pictures aren't that compelling
either whatever the [ __ ] you're putting
in the photo is [ __ ] just as good in
a video and I can get Hanks personality
out of it when you're like Hank Andy
cook turns over and I see his dimple and
it humanizes in more than a [ __ ]
still photo yeah okay dope dope pops me
you're gonna meet with pop says to you
now hey hey I'm used to it okay
you know to your point like every
promise you the tens of thousands of
people that are watching right now when
you said flooring photos are like but
that's cuz they don't need a floor your
point that photo is to somebody who
needed a floor I promise you that video
if you're holding your [ __ ] phone and
you're like Hank what are you doing
right now
the sealer doesn't [ __ ] need to go
with the [ __ ] and all of a sudden like
oh Sh you know like that should work
mm-hmm
because guess what happens when you
innovate okay pops you gave me four I'm
gonna [ __ ] this is what I get by the
way I'm giving you advice I lived Pop's
gave me a little room I did some ads it
[ __ ] worked pops didn't want to go to
next up I'm like okay I'm gonna [ __ ]
innovate over here to generate more so
if you go [ __ ] innovate with videos
and all of a sudden you're [ __ ] leads
8x and you like pops we had a tea leaves
before and you let me have four salesmen
now it's 600 [ __ ] 40 leads dad what
the [ __ ] do you want to do let's take
him just you and I hate him your pops
hired four people that would not be his
answer what you need to do is stop
worrying about his defense and you need
to take your offense to [ __ ]
legendary status word word is right well
nothing ecommerce how would you approach
ecommerce before um I don't know the
flooring sector super well is there a
lot of e-commerce work being like this
Home Depot or Lowe's or Amazon
yep a lot you know I would definitely
definitely definitely learn that how to
build a Shopify store if I were you you
think you look beautiful
I would [ __ ] build a Shopify store
and [ __ ] start selling [ __ ] and start
running ads and [ __ ] selling [ __ ] I
[ __ ] beat wine.com back in the day
the first one it was called wine shop er
it's on its fourth iteration now and
this team has done a good job with it
but [ __ ] not better in a wine tech
stock up by the way hey do you drink
wine I do not just pops
we do not anyway I would create a
Shopify store and I would literally
build it up and I would run Facebook ads
and it will work what I love is
localization Facebook is insane for
localization crazy especially for an
older demo that has the income to do
things like glory well in like to your
point very people always like no
Facebook won't work for my business
whenever I tell people flooring really
do flooring on Facebook yeah it's insane
it's called humans are on Facebook
especially if they're over 40 and if
they've got if they're over 40
oftentimes they have things they buy and
need
oh by the way the majority of things
that are sold in this country and
[ __ ] Facebook dominates and it's not
as cool as tic toc I'm not trying to be
cool out here I'm trying to build
businesses yeah so well verify your
Walker brother videos and on Facebook
Shopify keep putting pressure uh I think
that I love your ambition I also love
pops for delivering with for sales
people I do ya know he's awesome
you two are my biggest heroes I wish you
well tea time I don't know what else is
going on [ __ ] Internet I know at late
night oh by the way late night tonight 8
p.m.
Carmelo Anthony's what's in my glass
session I know he's been drinking wine
with some homies I'm joining so I'm when
I go live I'm sure you'll see that so 8
p.m. cest your [ __ ] alerts right now
8 p.m. on the Instagram tonight I will
be with Melo drinking some vino shooting
that [ __ ] so I don't know what the
[ __ ] going on in the internet right
now but if people are not watching this
if you do not screen shoot this and
share it if you do not take this URL and
share it in your Facebook groups your
e-mail newsletter your social media you
were holding out on your friends there's
[ __ ] dimes being dropped out here
[ __ ] let's keep it going what's good
hi Gary how you doing good man what's
your name my name is Shawn Shawn I love
the Michigan State [ __ ] with you it's
fresh what's going on Shawn so about uh
2013 I created uh a trail good rhymes
Twitter account and I post rhymes and I
built myself so numbers are pretty good
recently I bought a laser engraver I
make these little ladies wood engraved
nice thank you
yeah it's a it's a glowforge machine
it's a really cool machine so to make
content I have been giving these out for
free to my followers and I'm trying to
figure out when I should be asking for
money for these No
now okay yeah I mean my H is now only
sensing your energy that you might be
fearing going in for the ask
I've been jabbing a lot and I just have
yet no care you know it's funny when I
wrote Jab Jab Jab right hook I thought
that I was writing it for people that
were spamming and selling the whole time
and I wanted to teach them the jabbing
them romancing the bringing value what
ended up happening Sean is that the
feedback I got was from a lot of people
that are sweet and awesome like you who
actually were struggling with the ask
yeah let me let me say this Sean do not
fear the rejection of somebody saying no
do not fear that you're being a bad
person for asking you're asking you're
not demanding you're not manipulating
you're not tricking I feel no problem
asking for everybody to sign up for wine
text calm right now
no no hesitation I feel really good
right now look at that boom I love it
here's but here's why Sean do you
believe do you believe hello Dustin do
you believe in what you're selling I do
well listen in the process though I'm
okay good with the Machine so I don't
want to put out a bad product here's the
good news when you sell one if mrs.
Thompson
[ __ ] hits you back and says this is a
piece of [ __ ] you're like this is
Thompson I'm devastated send it back
I'll refund you or keep it and I'll
refund you you're in control of when
there's disappointment right that's true
yeah when you sell you have to believe
in what you sell and you have to be in
control of disappointment okay why have
I been going completely ham on this why
texting I'll tell you why cuz today
we're selling a $65 Cabernet that is
[ __ ] reading 95 points by one of the
hardest wine critics in the world let's
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] crazy good and it's
$29 and change when everybody's selling
it for 65 ok it's [ __ ] I [ __ ]
believe in it the most hmm and the way
you but like the texting thing is really
cool you should check it out but
nonetheless uh dream I know you can't
sign up and Utah for wine text but you
should buy empathy then anyway I had a
question about Wyatt x2 I am in Michigan
I will really short their state by state
laws and in certain states that don't
let retailer ship but they let wineries
[ __ ]
so Michigan Illinois Texas Utah I can't
ship I can't do white X but I didn't do
everything but Sean listen to me believe
it what you sell and remember you're in
control of if there's a problem that
should eliminate all of your fears when
you remember that you're just asking and
and don't be disappointed if nobody buys
because you can't have expectations of
customers we have to deliver for them
then they don't have to deliver for us
okay yeah it's like I post rhymes and I
and I get all sorts of shares and then
as soon as I post one of these things
that zero engagement which is well
that's because that world was built on
rhymes what you need to do you have a
couple dollars to potentially run ads I
run ads against my rhymes but not
against my product yes you you feel safe
in the rhymes world yeah you feel you
feel safe and good there we need to get
you to feel safe and good on the
woodwork okay awesome
all right thank you take care this is
good
DeWine text Thank You Sara
yeah the white X thing has been nuts
jay-bez please please please sign up for
wine text right now like actually I'm
taking uh cuz it takes so fat take so
it's super fast what am I doing here
hold on I am taking a I'm taking on
literally a 60-second break to actually
have an idea
yeah I'm taking a 60-second break just a
moment of silence to let everybody right
now go to the phone and send it to line
text if they are 21 if they live in a
state that we can ship not not white
still out not last bottle not wine calm
not some club that you got from Facebook
like no other platform is better than
wine text so I'm just can't wait if
you've signed up for white X during this
sixty second moment of silence please
leave a comment that you did I just
wanna see you'll be hard to me yes
Dustin please go on during this moment
of silence and
Thank You Craig Maillard and
congratulations on being sober for all
that time Thank You mind thank you to
signing up books and boarding passes
empathy kinship to Arkansas Luke 8 and
don't worry two more years for you what
are you like running a bath Dustin you
hear that I can hear everything
it's my cat's water fountain thing it's
so far away I didn't think you could
hear from you
okay [ __ ] hi oh no ice no we're gonna
get let's not take you off yet let's try
to figure it out while we're on together
shipping to me looks a day they are to
be knee-high hey Kerry greetings from
New Jersey what part
I live in Denville but I grew up in
North Brunswick
I love the Christine North Brunswick
super coast of Addison I love that yes
yeah well actually I'm a lawyer I love
that yeah that's part of my question
okay so I'm 45 I co-own a law firm doing
divorce law absolutely hate it
I'm totally miserable yeah what's what I
wanted to do at some point but it's not
anymore
yet and I hear you talk a lot to the 20
year olds about don't care what your
parents think do what you want to do be
happy don't chase the dollar and I think
that's great I love that message but I
feel like it's just I'm in such a
different place that I don't know if
it's applicable to me and I feel totally
trapped I don't know what to do to get
out of this situation that I'm in you're
trapped by the cost of your lifestyle
yes
so let's talk I need at least $10,000 a
month gross just to pay my bills but
that's not even happening I understand
that's because your lifestyle was built
around a career that you hate yeah what
do I do
the secret sauce is called humility I
mean yeah well I'm perfectly willing to
downsize I mean I have you know I really
want to go into broadcast journalism I'm
trying to figure out how to do that I
have no shame to marry five girl interns
I [ __ ] love everything everything
about this let's talk about downsizing
how real I want I
have an Excel spreadsheet with my budget
and I have whittled down everything that
I could possibly take out you know I do
help my family a little bit not a lot
but a little I respect it
you know not want to take that away from
them but I have life insurance I have
disability insurance I have a BMW that
you know is too expensive but I know
that I'm stuck with for another like 14
months and she is at least yeah I mean
there might I mean I'm not educated
enough but there might be some way to
bring it back to them and do something
with and 14 months is not the worst
either so let's take a step back are you
willing to sell your home I rent so fair
enough fair enough
um look I think I think that look so a
couple things the other thing you can do
because a lot of people can't even
downsize because you know they can't so
let's play a different game what you can
do is use and this is my first book I
wrote crush it was during 2008 during
this time and I my big theory then was
like look you've got to pay your bills
and you've got to maintain your
lifestyle whatever that may be whether
it's a thousand bucks a month or ten
thousand bucks a month so why don't you
really focus on 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the
morning right and and when I hear about
broadcast journalism like if I'm you I
start a Facebook live show immediately
at night literally tea with Gary B but
like like wine with Kristina and like
literally start [ __ ] interviewing
people like literally spend seven or
eight to ten booking people and for the
next day like doing it every other day
one night is booking people the next day
is interviewing them and put your
abilities on film like literally give
people the look like one of the ways you
can do this there's two ways to do it
you downsize so much that you can
actually sell your partnership to your
partner or a different lawyer take those
dollars have a nest egg and go for a
year or two trying to go into journalism
or you can maintain your lifestyle ish
14 months definitely [ __ ] everyone's
opinions on your BMW get something else
lower that lower everything and then
work at night to build your new world
which will then lead to speaking or
books or a job actually kind of do the
flip you like you're doing it you're
like fixing the plane while you're on it
and then you can make the switchover
because now instead of 10,000 being an
issue you can you can you're gonna get a
$6,000 offer you cut your expenses by
4000 and you see where I'm going you
kind of flip there so that's but you
need to create content and put yourself
out there to create the opportunity and
that has to happen at night late night
yeah I have a podcast but I have been
thinking about making it a Facebook live
interview you have them a show show the
world what you are and the Internet now
let's that happen I mean I've turned
down [ __ ] 500 TV show offers and it
happened because I because I put myself
I put myself in that position in 2006
with a wine show you know and then later
business content like you can do that
too you mean now get 500 but good news
is you only need one yeah you have to
listen to me what's probably happening
is you have an intense job you know you
come home probably late you're probably
working at home sometimes as well and
then you need to be a human and what
[ __ ] watch the news have a glass of
wine do some [ __ ] right what you need to
do is realize realize you're unhappy and
so you have to turn those hours at night
into becoming the next version of
yourself well I have a partner too and I
think I feel a little you know guilty
like sometimes just I don't know
abandoning him or leaving him because
he's either that's very sweet so so
encourage him to let him watch his
[ __ ] video like encourage him to yeah
I mean there's there's tons of bigger
law firms that would love to sweep up
your client list or your brand yeah I
mean I'd love to be in a position to
sell the firm I I don't at this point I
don't need to be rich I think when you
get miserable
happy you know I don't need to drag
around in the BMW nobody gives a [ __ ] do
you think people are so confused as if
you get like one good day from your
buddies this pretty youngsters out there
are the people that are about to buy a
fit I mean when you talk about nobody
giving a [ __ ] about a fancy fancy car
what do you think is happening
somebody envies you for a day who gives
you [ __ ] yeah it's true nobody gives a
[ __ ] and that goes too close and that
goes to your photo on you on a boat like
like I don't know people are seeing it
but what's happening on Instagram right
now is people are starting to resent
people who are flexing this is just high
school you know freshmen and sophomore
year you think the prettiest girl and
the coolest guy are [ __ ] awesome by
the time you're in the last half of
senior year you think you're [ __ ]
douchebags well it looks like flexing -
yeah listen some people really love the
way a BMW drives and they can afford it
and [ __ ] amazing
we're always their whole life they
dreamed about having a Jaguar and they'd
understand [ __ ] amazing but so many
people buy it because they think they're
supposed to or they subconsciously need
that affirmation yeah listen I get it
Christina I'm not put please no this is
not judgment I'm with you
twenty-seven-year-old you versus 40 for
you I get it everyone goes through the
same things but beauty is nobody on TV
or magazine or or radio was talking
about this [ __ ] back then thank God we
have the internet now that you were kids
we're in the same agent we're still kid
we a [ __ ] City
you didn't live for 50 more years you
want to be miserable for another 30
professional years no way so so if
you're in a spot where you feel kind of
like me look renting in New Jersey and
Dembo is different than renting in New
Jersey and Edison or renting in New
Jersey in [ __ ] Springfield like you
you're in control of your humility if
that hurts too much which I have a lot
of empathy for then you need to really
focus on your nights and start building
your new future but those are the only
two [ __ ] prescriptions that work I
hold once you get to your misery
threshold you don't even care
it's [ __ ] box you know it's so funny
Philadelphia fans said move to PA it's
really been interesting either you know
cuz I mean I grew up my high school
years I grew up in my childhood years in
Edison but my high school years in
Hunterdon County New Jersey which is
like exit like 12 15 on 78th out west
and I'm seeing a lot of people in the
Springfield Edison Bergen County area
start to really consider like right over
the bridge by Phillipsburg and like it's
just there's so many options to your
point when you're [ __ ] unhappy yeah
the BMW's not important after a while
nobody gives a [ __ ]
no but there's a lot of people my age
that are there over you know they're
just over saddled with a mortgage I
don't even have that I'm lucky I don't
have kids because I don't have those
responsibilities but I hear so many
people say well what am I suppose to
know ya know nobody has the humility to
move nobody has the courage to go and
say to their wife we're moving like like
what people don't realize is this is why
so many people are on opioids and
alcohol and just like they're sad then
they're spending more money to go to
therapy you know like it just it's it's
tough man this is why happen we have to
read it but listen it is our
responsibility we grew up in in a gen-x
world where like success mattered like
things mattered and like it's our
responsibility to educate these kids and
ourselves that we need to shed this [ __ ]
and what you need to make happiness to
ROI not [ __ ] money yeah it's really
true it's super [ __ ] true wait for
people to see it what do I do to get it
get it in front of the right people work
on getting instead of spamming people
and say watch my show what you want to
do is reach out to people on DM like
crazy on Instagram DM the biggest names
Katie Couric or [ __ ] Gayle King or
[ __ ] LeBron literally asking being
relentless to ask do you want to be on
my
uh and then the means that you land
I'd rather you land and spam VIPs that
are on the show that then bring
awareness to your show then hitting up
executives and saying look how good I am
at this yeah I promise you if you do the
show agents and networks and talent
firms and managers will start reaching
out I get them I mean I just go back to
my time I was good at it in 2006 CAA
William Morris Endeavor managers
networks I was getting bombarded when
you're good you're good and sometimes it
takes time to be good sometimes you're
born with it but you have a very good
presence like I can feel that already I
mean that thank you thank you Jersey
girl that spend spend time on getting
the guests that will work out what you
want you don't it's kind of like you
know it's kind of like girl boy dynamics
if you can create a world where it's
coming to you versus you're chasing it
you'll always have the leverage awesome
will you be on my show I will be on your
show if you get 15 other guests
I'll show me that you're in and then you
email me and say Gary you're number 16
its Gary at vaynermedia you show me the
15 guess and it can't be your [ __ ]
aunt I need to see real [ __ ] all right
all right all right you got it
take care you got it bye-bye ready New
Jersey by the way anybody New Jersey
who's not part of wine texts anybody in
New Jersey who's not part of wine texts
if you're buying from [ __ ] bottle
king or total wine or some [ __ ] I'm
gonna [ __ ] anybody in New Jersey
who's not signed up for wine texts I'm
[ __ ] let's keep it going
hello oh my gosh oh it's good okay
okay hi hi hi what's your name please
Jamil Jamil and I put it here I'm sorry
it's like a delay my Posse's no worries
- you're good okay cool
so just to give you a little bit of
backstory about me I grew up in a super
small town Sanford North Carolina
shoutout to Bojangles and I actually
moved here to now moved here to Las
Vegas with my grandparents when I was 8
years old my grandfather owned his own
business and New York so I'm a little
bit nervous he owned his own business in
New York and he was shining shoes then
he came here to Las Vegas a little bit
later with us and owned his own business
at the Wynn encore shining shoes as well
so with that entrepreneurship has just
been kind of in my blood I wanted to
sell hair weave when I was in college I
wanted to sew like snacks at school when
I was in high school so essentially I
started my own cosmetic line called the
unicorn Locker cosmetics and our
business or my business is built upon
empowering women with knowledge and
understanding that you can be anybody
you want to be it doesn't matter where
you come from it doesn't matter how you
grew up the life that you lived who
raised you
none of that I want to mentor young
girls we offer cosmetics between I
products lip products skin products and
things like that so essentially I've
been listening to you for years now and
I was able to earn thirty five thousand
followers on tik-tok and it means a lot
to me because those little girls have so
many comments with so much positivity
and it lets me know that there are not
people who I don't think anybody's this
is kind of a side note I don't think
anybody's born racist or hateful because
there's so many people it's torn a seat
a beer dude it's taught they're so kind
and they're like eight years old so I'm
like there's no way that you you grew up
and then you know you became this
horrible person so essentially what I'm
trying to do is learn how to funnel
people from my tick-tock to my Instagram
and then to my website for sales so I so
you you you have the URL to your website
in your Instagram obviously right yes
how much content on tick-tock are you
putting to give awareness that you're on
Instagram actually not very much I guess
I
yeah I misunderstood I guess I thought
that they would not show the content if
I mention a different platform or
something like that
nope okay okay and then I had also seen
your previous comments to a couple other
people last week about posting maybe
once or twice a day letting people know
hey I want to give you some incentives
to head over to my Instagram spend some
time with you if you've already to be or
you could be creative where you start a
skit on a piece of content on tick-tock
and then you say right at the end oh you
want to see the end of this go to my
Instagram now and boom so you can do a
little bit of that play okay I'm going
okay you can make a post on tick-tock
tick-tock I'm doing its rim live tonight
at 7:00 p.m.
leave a comment if you're in I'll reply
I'll see you tonight at 7:00 p.m. my
Instagram is the same as it is here on
tic-tac be sure I'm going yes okay okay
perfect perfect so with that I also used
the content structure that she posted
it's as far as repurposing content I
also use the join join team garyvee blog
that she posted about how we would make
content for you and I try to use that
for me and I find that it really helps
however my time management gets a little
bit skewed because I make everything
myself SEO website products graphics
videos pictures everything so how how do
I use that structure to my advantage
when I have all these other things that
I'm doing by not judging yourself I
didn't have anybody there for 10 years
yeah patient name okay cool cool and
important real quick everybody's
watching I get on my own everyone's like
you got a team you got do you wrap at
Dustin like I [ __ ] did it for 10
years so look through me drew by myself
okay cool call me you know everybody
sees me this now they didn't see 2004
they didn't see 2001 then in C 2006 they
didn't see 2009 you can go on YouTube in
five videos of me that has [ __ ] 49
views you can go on Twitter and find
posts that got one like right tight
everybody's right now go type in Gary B
2008 on Twitter search right now you'll
see posts that have four likes
zero
like how do you how do you time manage
by not judging yourself
and not people spend more time feeling
bad and dwelling and judging themselves
about their time management which is
[ __ ] up their time in it right back
that you beat yourself up that you
didn't do it well enough or I'm
scattered praying or I [ __ ] near sir
it's always gonna be like this if you
[ __ ] see that every second that you
spend on dwelling and beating yourself
up on I'm actually doing [ __ ] you
wouldn't be [ __ ] stressing about time
management right man okay big facts okay
cool cool so I also have a lot of people
who look at my post I can see my
engagement see the video video views and
things like that on Instagram however
they're not navigating to my site so I'm
trying to figure out what am I doing
wrong I like to give them a lot of tips
post a lot of content so once once in a
while I mean how often do you post on
Instagram ah probably maybe two to three
times a day great one of those or go to
four times a day
okay straight up through a hard core
right look and be like yo go to my
website okay obviously way more creative
than that right you know what I mean but
like yo I'm doing this on my website or
put up something on your website that's
look what I did I put out a deck that
cost me a lot of money and time that I
didn't sell it
there's all sorts of [ __ ] trying to
sell [ __ ] for $5,000 or 3,000 you know
what I mean right why don't you put out
a nice piece of content why don't you
put out a self-esteem for 12 year olds
deck on your website so then when you
say go to my website you feel proud that
there's something there gonna get some
value that I agree I agree so I also
have a blog that I just recently began
as well and I'll be reaching out to
different makeup artists and Facebook
groups to happen I apologize just go yes
four times a day I post four times a day
on Instagram four times a day keep going
no problem so actually hmm lost my train
of thought but I apologize for no it
happens to me a lie oh you said you just
started blogging
yes I just started blogging and I'm also
going to be reaching out to makeup
artist and Facebook groups asking them
for their tips so that way they could be
featured inside of the blog bringing you
the blogging things like that so I do
feel a little bit better when people
come to the site they actually have
something to look at
so with that as far as my actual site
SEO how important is SEO if you're
working on building a brand I spent a
lot of time creating content and I also
trying to leverage my time with SEO on
my website so I can actually show up on
Google so how important is that for a
startup it's important but I think that
it's a very complex very mature business
and then a lot of people a lot of small
people can't win that SEO game as much
as they think I can win the tic-tock
game like you did right so it's
important but I but me personally I'm a
believer at this moment that most small
players need to focus on social content
raise their funds up and potentially
hire outside SEO cuz it's so mature
right okay oh and I like that you know
what it is so when you do pay somebody
on the outside you don't get caught
cuz man oh yeah yeah and I also took a
google analytics course I got Google
Analytics certified after bringing in my
stats to be able to determine exactly
what's going on so basically I think I
think that's pretty much all that I that
I needed oh one more thing though one
thing
I know Magda stallion is your pal can
you plug me so I consider some glitter
thank you
talk to you soon bye bye bye go back to
that guy who said I was piece of [ __ ]
it's a great point I really appreciate
him gonna find it no worries raspberries
are underrated but I can just speak to
it yeah it is really interesting that
aggressiveness and high energy confuses
people at first so if you're on a
youtube or Twitter right now watching
and at first when you first saw me
you're like [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] but
this just reply now me I just want to
see how many me alright let's keep going
I be very very [ __ ] jump Chris oh
[ __ ] what feel like I'm 14 again in the
early 90s and I just called my favorite
radio station and I'm caller number 7 I
love it Chris were you at Colorado very
nice it's good to see you nice you too
brother homesteader yeah I mean my wife
left our corporate corporate lives and
sold all the [ __ ] we didn't need and
moved out to the middle of nowhere just
trying to document the journey on
YouTube and how do you be yourself or
how do I be my nerdy ass self in front
of the camera because when I'm so low
with it like I just clam up I understand
so Chris I think it comes down to taking
a big step back and really really really
thinking about the following why in the
world especially when you have such a
[ __ ] epic red beard why in the world
would you ever ever ever let somebodies
anonymous opinion stop you from telling
your truth literally right before you
came on right now and I think you
probably heard it I asked a question of
how many of you went first saw B thought
I was [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy
I just while you were talking and I was
wiring your background I saw him on
godly amount of people say me you can
imagine as a human that doesn't know
great it's just that I conditioned
myself at this point to be empathetic to
other people's opinions because they
don't know me
same with you brother you could be nerdy
because it doesn't matter if people
think you're nerdy or boring or not
boring you just gotta keep persevering
you're gonna find your crew you're gonna
find your crew right a lot of people
that because that I mean there's
probably what 10,000 people watching
this right now and I can talk to you and
conjunct a coherent sentence but when
I'm solo with the camera like my brain
just goes to mush and I can't organize
my thoughts
I gotta make yeah it's really funny
what's that have a similarity to me I
actually hate being solo too
I need action notice I'm bringing yes
how I am I do better interacting when I
did wine rbtv I made Kastner and Chris
Maat Maat people used to think I said
ma-mutt those people behind the camera I
used to interact with them because I
needed the action when I did a scary V I
made India and stunwin
and those characters part of it I'm
doing T with Gary B I'm making Dustin a
part of it so what you may want to do is
when you make videos you may want to go
on on Facebook live or YouTube live and
do it live because you're getting a
little bit of that human interaction
that you're feeling right now or right
right you might need a virtual co-host
hmm
how would you do that you would do it I
mean we're co-hosts right now okay that
makes sense right you go go to scream
yard com that's like a platform you
buddies you know somebody you think
could be good at this and maybe maybe
what you need is a co-host
some people are way better with co-hosts
and they are solo so how would I
incorporate that and with like my daily
things that I have to do when I'm
homesteading that I wanted ah Q when
you're homesteading and documenting you
don't even need to talk to camera maybe
you just document it and then you do
voice over with you and that person
after the fact in post-production okay
so you see what's awesome about this
Chris is what I what is always driven me
is the ability to have ideas and to
always look for yes like there's nothing
you or anybody else can say that's gonna
stop me or make me say well we can't
there's always things to do the fact
that you can document what you're doing
and then do post-production voiceover
might be the unlock want to think about
for sure you like that right good idea
I mean you know maybe you feel way more
comfortable watching your day and even
talking about what was on your mind as a
matter of fact that's a good idea for me
for daily be like like the coolest [ __ ]
is actually in my mind that you can't
see what I'm saying out loud right right
as entertaining and smart as it is I
promise you it's [ __ ] secondary to
what's going on in here right and yeah
I spend a lot of time because well I
mean I have my wife and my kids and
whatnot but I do a lot of solo projects
around here so I spend a lot of time
internalizing yeah I think filming that
as quote-unquote boring as it may seem
and what you're doing I would argue it
isn't especially if you voiceover and be
like yo I was looking at this [ __ ]
plant or doing this or the [ __ ] you're
doing right by the way what's your
channel you it's getting people
bombarded me for what your channel is oh
it's a bar none good bar with two hours
bar bar what bar none off-grid and
what's the what's dustin you got that
because I know we're gonna put the link
here is that it wait girl Chris can you
see that
what's that oh yeah yeah that's it all
one word right youtube I know it's
separated just like he wrote it Chris I
wish you luck I'm telling you right now
I really like the idea of you just
filming it and then taking it into
post-production and talking over it okay
do you think you can do that works out
and talk to me nah I don't know I don't
know I think it's it's still it's
probably better than me being solo with
the camera trying to talk to it but it's
still just me talking like I don't know
I don't know I I guess maybe I am like
you nectar sect is like I do way better
in an interactive scenario why don't you
try going live on YouTube or Facebook
for the whole day and interacting with
the phone see how that feels
okay yeah yeah yeah I've never tried
livestream on YouTube but I don't really
have a lot of followers so there's
people watch if I went live Chris when I
went live on Ustream back in the day
back in the back back back day I [ __ ]
had like 70 people in there and they
became my family and it became 13 and 13
became 22 you know what you can do is
before you go live the first time why
don't you go to your address book and
text literally everybody
YouTube channels say listen tomorrow's a
big day for me I'm gonna go live and I
just need some people in there and it
would mean a lot to me if you came
you're gonna have six to 15 friends jump
in there okay Chris you don't I mean I
don't I don't know what Mike said Chris
you just went up a hundred followers on
your Youtube subscriber list since we've
been talking kiddin be kidding me
that's [ __ ] fantastic Wow I don't
know what to say to that right now well
guess what here's what I have to say to
it now you have a base now you have a
base of people that will join you on
your first YouTube live take advantage
of it my friend use this serendipitous
moment to start the next chapter right
right just got a grind and kill it you
have 35 followers now you have 142 Jesus
that's the same it's a good bar hey I
appreciate it brother I appreciate you
let's drop his channel one more time
Dustin Chris have a great great day hey
thanks Gary love you you got I love you
back it's been the last couple of
minutes they're so low you know she kept
doing this this way let's recap today's
recap look just doing nice things I
think all of you first and foremost you
as a community thank you so so so so so
much for for following Chris's channel
that means a lot to me you can see we
made that wonderful man's day there's a
lot of a lot of patience a lot of inside
your own head if you really think about
the themes it's so funny back to the
thing we did where it was me me me I can
come across hard and aggressive in
Jersey and cursing and and I can look
like a lot of the spammy people that are
just trying to get you into funnels and
[ __ ] I get it but the reality is the
religion here is patience and kindness
and empathy and and and self esteem and
self awareness and kindness and empathy
and I just really appreciate having this
time with you guys to really keep
pounding that home and I think more and
more every single day it's becoming more
obvious to people what's really
happening here couple things I want to
end up with one please
please share this show I really think
we're doing something meaningful and I
want more people more people you know
there's a lot of people who do think of
a douchebag and maybe they watching two
or three or new people I think we're
doing a lot of good here and so I also
know this format is probably not
sustainable and will be over somewhere
here in the next 30 or 60 days so if you
can take a screenshot and post it to all
your places text friend start a whatsapp
group like your Facebook group moderator
for sure please spread this love far and
wide that would mean a lot to me and I
just appreciate it Dustin come in here
let's chat for a few minutes as we wrap
up the show what do you see what did you
see out there today a lot of good
comments not really not too many bad
comments or anything like that that's
why I was trying to show them but I
couldn't find too many a couple spam
stuff Jonathan Smith tea time starts
every morning at 9:00 a.m. Eastern 6:00
a.m. on the west coast by the way I
guess he's up to 300 he's at 400
subscribers now what a reasonable love
what a critical what else do you see yes
unfortunately I wasn't being able to pay
attention because there's a lot going on
here so a lot of it just went in one ear
went out the other I respect that we're
gonna figure out the facebook comments
for tomorrow yeah it was a good show
yeah there were some really good ones
yeah I mean which did you get anything
stand out to you or were you like so
introduced remote just contact just a
guy that was like in tears right away I
was like whoa yeah I really like the kid
that really got it the patience thing
like the framework I forgot which one
that was he was the kid that I was like
you're putting a time limit on your
ambition mm-hmm lot of people a lot of
people in the comments we're like wow
wow wow and stuff like that when that
happened the stakes were hard work thank
you for hooking it up with steam yards
steam yard big shout out we're enjoying
the platform I think you liked it yes
matters to me let me okay cool you out
of here
dust throw up wine texture right now I'm
gonna spend the last five four minutes
guilting people to sign up for up it's
just a very simple guilt if you buy wine
from anybody else besides me I'm
struggling
that if you don't mind don't buy don't
sign up for wine text I don't need to
sign up it cost money Senate X don't
sign up at all if you're not a wine
buyer but if you buy wine it would mean
the world to me to support my dad okay
and now let's finish up with some shout
outs on the way out list life thank you
for watching
Allah ie ly Murphy was in your shirt the
whole time big shout out the cherry
picker I really appreciate you thank you
for being here
Oh as a matter of fact if you were on
YouTube or Twitter right now please
reply with what state you live in give
me a little shout out also throw it up
to one two nine three one five seven
three one if you are if you are looking
to get on this show as I know a lot of
you are please please text to 1 2 9 3 1
5 7 3 1 your question put hashtag tea
with Gary Vee so the team can find it
I'm probably gonna send out a blast to
everybody on Clark's to join tea with
Gary Vee community so you look for that
will tell you how to do that big shout
out to Sydney Australia for Mika rich
Klein in New York you better sign up for
a wine text Thank You bat Thank You
Vicki there big shout out big shout out
to Scott from Indiana big shout out to
bond in Utah good to see you Jenny good
to see you
alright final part right now take a
screenshot of this will not be good with
the white text take a screenshot of this
actually not this not this this how I
wanna end because I want to really say
thank you back to the white X Dustin if
you sign up for my attacks please tweet
me Gary Vee with your screenshot of the
confirmation sign up a little see ya
love you we'll see you tomorrow 9 a.m.
tea with Gary Vee be nice today it's
always the right answer
okay so team Gary has made a lot of
content over the years but what's your
favorite piece of content that was made
a great question my favorite content by
far is I'm considering doing a
vaynermedia Operations stay-at-home day
once a week forever because I'm I'm
pretty sold that I've gotten more done
per day then sometimes at a month